welcome back to the Rich Eisen show not
just to the radio and television viewing
audience but right now to the man to my
right we just saw a great clip of his
new original series The Witcher
available for streaming on Netflix
Friday December 20th starring Henry
Cavill good to see you again sir
now we just saw you in this and you know
you definitely look like you spent a lot
in the makeup chair for this series am I
correct in assuming that yeah it was a
two hours at least every morning every
morning yeah for the blonde hair or is
that all it was yeah for the wig was a
big deal and my skin super pale as well
and so they have spent all the time
doing that then dirting me up afterwards
and there's another look which you don't
see here but in the show and that takes
two and a half hours ha to get ready for
okay and yeah you know it definitely
gives you time to learn your lines in
the morning oh so you're not just like
strolling instagrams no no it's it's
yeah line learning your professional is
basically what you're saying
henry cavill by the way on instagram so
why did you choose this role in this
show this series henry i have been a big
fan of the IP for a while now and I
first was introduced to it via the games
like series on which this is based
yes yes and then I learned that there
were games books and that's written by a
guy called her Andrew sepkoski mm-hmm
and the books are absolutely fantastic
really really good dark fantasy typical
fantasy tropes gnomes elves towards all
of that kind of stuff but it's set in
this really grim world where there
aren't any good people or bad people
there's just everyone trying to trying
to get along well they're not getting
along the exact opposite of what they're
doing
rayul murdering each other and clonely
as I'm in xenophobia and everything but
the setting is fantastic he had these
amazing characters like the guy you saw
in there girls who were despite looking
like someone who will kill you and then
the blink of an eye he's he's actually a
white knight and he tries through the
best to protect the innocent that he can
but you sought this role out you're the
one who absolutely yeah why I mean you
just love the games like love the games
the games are especially which are three
super immersive and I don't have anyone
has a game or anything livin was played
the games but it's super immersive and
when I was playing it I always thought
it'd make a great movie or TV show and
yeah and then I do that a lot with a lot
of games a lot of games and books and
then I heard that Netflix were making it
and have Maiden's on the phone every day
literally every day I could call them
and say anything yet call him again and
we got through eventually and they said
look we've we haven't got a script yet
and we've barely got a showrunner so we
can't we can't give you an answer but
you front loaded your interest
yes that's gonna help they knew that I
wanted it for sure for sure so I know I
might be offending people out there when
I say that when I think of gamers I
think of a guy in his sweats you know
some chips Fritos just sitting around
things I like sweat seriously yeah yeah
really
absolutely okay I mean we're not all the
time oh you know I'm saying clearly not
yeah but I mean that's how you give me
give me the the gaming I guess what's
your gaming mancave look like my gaming
I mean what do you look like while
you're I wouldn't but I'm glad I
eventually got to what I wanted to maybe
one of these days I'll send you a photo
yeah
please send game just facetiming yeah
Henry asked matter if you're gaming yeah
a live streaming but what is this what
does it look like I mean what we're
really like I don't have a man cave I've
I've got a small Mews house in London
what amuses it's like an old stables
okay and they've been converted to
houses over the years okay and it's not
huge so my computer desk is in my very
small living room right and it's just at
the end there that's it nothing well
nothing special oh that's just a
converted barn
rather converts not even converted barn
it's not stables themselves they're all
separate houses yeah so it's one set of
stable yes this doesn't sound like any
gaming experience ever and does look
like a stables are there's not like
sawdust enforcing the wrong kind of
picture believe that believe why not
just get the hair the way I can't see my
controller
so what else do what else do you play I
mean I play PC games okay rather than
console games okay but total wars a big
one for me okay it's like a strategic
world conquest type thing you know okay
so are you out there like where somebody
is just gaming against you they have no
idea that they possibly are in a virtual
world with Henry Cavill Croft yeah yeah
but that's the only one online game I
play for now okay I don't overwatch but
yeah yeah those are pretty very popular
there's a big one what did G so do you
watch some of the professional gaming do
you ever sit around that's what Bailey
have time to play myself these days that
and so if I'm watching pro gamers I'm
not a waiting game I have a buddy of
mine who owns one of these teams okay
okay not just they're a big deal they're
huge yeah I mean they're beginning to
give out scholarship of like like the
actual academic scholarships absolutely
at big universe but I don't know what
the hell I'm looking at I mean it's just
and my friend is like oh we're close
we're close to winning and I'm like okay
I have no earthly you can follow that
sort of stuff though um depends on the
game okay yeah alright yeah I've got
Henry Cavill here on the Rich Eisen show
so the Witcher is available again for
streaming on Friday December 20th so
you're in the makeup chair for all this
time and how have you liked what you've
seen out of the finished product is this
what your you were looking for well it's
it's when you're making a TV show it's
always very very when you're making an
adaptation of books or games
yes it's always gonna be different
because there is the games is just a
complete book so does completely
different medium you can have pages and
pages of monologue which is describing a
character and in a TV show you can't
have that unless you want people to not
watch the TV show right and as far as
I'm aware that's not the goal so
they've they've definitely they've
definitely Lauren has brought her own
vision Lauren historic the showrunner
yes she's brought her own vision to this
and it is in essence very very much what
the books are portraying but in a in a
TV TV format well I mean everyone who
did Game of Thrones will say that if
anybody thinks that you're not staying
true to the books you'll hear about it I
mean so I'm sure you're kind of prepared
for that sort of but you can also say
I've gained it I've read it you know
everybody back off I mean in a much
nicer way than I just said absolutely
absolutely no it's with especially what
Lauren's done she's come onto this and
she's she's been very courageous taking
on such a popular IP yes and she as I
say she's brought her own vision to this
in the books we have three major
characters one of which doesn't really
get introduced until the second book and
one of which gets introduced at the end
of the first book and otherwise you're
just following Geralt and Lauren has
brought her a far broader lens to this
TV show and we have these two fantastic
characters yennefer in ciri who are
introduced from the very beginning and
so it to draw parallels between the
books and the TV show is going to be
very very difficult from the beginning
yes because we have three major
characters from the get-go rather than
one the essence of everything is the
same and people will recognize certain
elements of of the books but this is
very much a broader lens version of what
the books represent well the last time
you were here Henry you were here we
were talking about Mission Impossible
fall out and you did your own stunts in
that yeah pretty much
oh but one all of 1/b was at the
helicopter that was no helicopter I did
do that was freezing but these the halo
jump they skydive but you wanted to do
this oh I want to do it so badly I was
asking from the very beginning but they
said without the right kind of training
you're gonna end up or something's gonna
happen and both you and Tom will be dead
producers that's a nightmare well sure
it's terrible I mean let alone my mother
in life that you killed Tom Cruise
you're
how dare you do that and why do you want
to do your own stunts
what's the when it comes to doing stunts
for me when it comes to embodying
character I want when the audience are
watching it's about audience immersion
yes I want them when they see something
fantastic or spectacular
I don't want part of their brain to be
saying that stuntman was really good
because then that's breaking the
immersion the character if they know
that it's me doing it in the same way
that when you're watching Tom Cruise you
know that it's Tom Cruise doing it right
you are so fully involved in that even
if you see actors you are emotionally
connected to what they're doing more so
than that little part of your
subconscious saying but that's not them
that's something someone else and stunt
performers are amazing remarkable people
just really are but I want to have some
fun too so that's why I do it what's the
crazy henry cavill here in the Rich
Eisen show what's the craziest thing
you've done was it that Hilo the
craziest thing I've done was probably
the helicopter stuff on mission that was
really crazy I mean Tom Cruise is his
helicopter was so close to mine at
points that I was definitely thinking
that is it I was looking down yet
genuinely think of this if he makes one
mistake if there's a gust of wind and
his helicopter gets blown forward or
mine back or vice versa this could end
up really really badly and he's a great
helicopter pilot and my helicopter part
was fantastic as well but he was
literally lying his helicopter I was in
the back of my helicopter yes that was
long for the ride I was just along for
the ride
yeah acting when I realized the cameras
rolling on me sometimes acting when they
weren't so genuine waste of energy yeah
but it it got to a point where I was
looking at the ground thinking if we do
crash one my chance of surviving one the
crash
helicopter crashes notoriously difficult
to survive apparently and to living in
the mountains with hopefully Tom Cruise
and my pilot
and making a documentary about it man so
this swordplay you're doing the
swordplay in The Witcher right yes
was there any close calls on that front
or there's always close calls of
swordplay especially in episode one
there's a particularly technical scene
oh gosh required a lot of hard work
Wolfgang Stegman who is the fight
coordinator for episode one and his team
and I designed this fight to be
technical very very difficult sure and
and Lucy cork was the stunt performer
who was doubling em Alton and Lucy and I
were going to the very top of our
ability and speed and we definitely took
chunks out of each other's hands no
kidding for sure yeah you end up hitting
each other quite a bit it's about not
complaining about it
especially we're doing it over and over
and over again you're exhausted and
wolfy is a an exceptional professional
and he expects very very high standard
damn and so when he says okay let's do
another one then you know another one
needs to be done yeah but it's it's
minut details can I stop and ask for
neosporin in a band-aid yes but it would
not be be somewhat frowned upon yes
homicide in community now when you were
when you were here last time again for
mission that scene in the bathroom where
you had that fight scene you said that
you shot that over an absurd amount of
time right that was something it was
something like four weeks I think
is there anything similar obviously
we're talking about a feature film there
and yes but this is a weird couple days
or something that don't have the luxury
of time on a TV show I bet not that was
that was right at the end during
reshoots as well did I just show my
complete lack of knowledge but notable
feature filmmaking that involves Tom
Cruise and helicopters formed by Tom
Cruise I think Tom Cruise may be the
major difference but also this this
looks this looks beautiful
this show looks amazing good you know
it's that's that's what we were going
for okay yeah everybody took about two
and a half days maybe three days to
shoot that's a significant but you know
it's hard see it's a me I mean Henry
Cavill you're like you're you're you're
flying helicopters you're gaming and
in not in a barn but in a remade sort of
barn and then your I mean swinging
swords that's that serious businessman
so it is fun no but how heavy is this
thing it depends on the sort the real
sword is reasonably heavy like you
wouldn't want to swing it out someone
and then right be required to stop it
hmm and so they do have these lighter
weight swords there's hard rubber and
soft rubber soft rubber is for very very
close stuff which if you do hit someone
it's not gonna hurt that much right the
hard rubber if you do hit someone at
full speed it still hurts a lot right
but it's not gonna take a finger off or
break a bone it'll just break the skin
if you're going pretty fast
okay well look man it's always great to
be in something that you love so much
that you wanted it you asked for it and
lobbied for it you got it you made it
and before it even streams for a single
second season two's already been picked
up yeah we're excited you know
and Netflix being international I mean
the stuff on it is just unbelievable and
is the fact that I mean everything
that's on there right now and now the
witcher's gonna get added on Friday
December 20th and I imagine you got to
hit the gym for for season two right now
based on everything's yeah I'll be
starting I mean I'm kind of starting on
tour now a little bit but then I'll take
a break of a Christmas New Year and
restarting again properly in January
okay I've got to have my Christmas you
know what I don't you see this is what I
think of like you're gonna be sitting
there you're gonna be gaming and you're
just gonna have all that Christmas stuff
in front of you and you're just gonna
eat it right that yeah all the christmas
foods i if i did that see all I do is I
sit on my ass that's all I do yeah
you're looking at is what I do I sit on
my ass and I talk and then I get up but
boy can you talk okay you know what
Henry I appreciate you saying that
you know it takes a lot about two and a
half hours in the chair that's what I do
every day about two and a half three
hours in the chair but and then and then
I go work out and then I do it again
you know just keep going on and on and
on then either nice thanks I could
listen to you I should I complain about
all right
yeah I've been playing tennis lately
okay and my left foot is killing me
right plantar fasciitis okay it's crazy
sounds bad you know what I you know what
I try not to
about it um and I try not to talk about
it but I always want to just eventually
just get it out there with everybody
what what is it well what it is is it's
the bottom of your foot has something
you know you're straining it in a way
yep and your heel just kills you okay
especially after you're sitting around
for a long time
Oh challenge resting yeah I got to get
up and about I got to do more swordplay
in my work yes every solution for
everything you know what it's all in The
Witcher it's all in The Witcher
streaming on Friday December 20th I
really appreciate when you stop by here
thank you very much but a lot of fun
last time this time you always have a
home here whenever you want to promote
anything or not certainly if you want to
you know game a little bit we can do
that too okay maybe maybe like the gamer
Henry Cavill The Witcher a game a book
series and now streaming Friday December
20th on Netflix for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app